this is Jocko podcasts number 117 with
echo Charles and me Jacque a willing
good evening echo good evening and we're
doing a Q&A tonight first one in a while
had a bunch of other guests and books
and whatnot
so cue a let's go cool first question
Jocko from 1/15 podcast number 115 as a
leader how best to respond to someone
like corporal Meyer when he brings up
good questions in in a brief that need
to be addressed without derailing the
brief and calling your competence slash
authority into question okay so what
he's talking about is on podcast 115
with Dakota Meyer which if you haven't
listened to it and listen to it it's
long and it's very I don't know it's
it's awesome anyways in part of that
podcast Dakota is getting told how
they're gonna conduct this operation and
Dakota raises some point and says what
about this what about that and what
about this other thing and they don't
listen to him and so the question here
is if you're in charge you're the leader
and you get someone that brings up these
questions during a brief during a plan
that you need to be that need to be
addressed how do you do it how do you
handle that properly okay well first of
all and the most important part of this
is if you involve your team in the
planning itself you won't have these
questions come up during the brief
they'll come up during the planning
mm-hmm so that's that's the ultimate and
best way to solve this problem you don't
plan in a vacuum as the leader and then
present the plan to the troops and
expect that you're gonna have the
perfect plan you didn't use only your
brain working on it what about everyone
else's brain what about everyone else's
perspective they have experience and
they have knowledge that you don't have
so if you involve them in the planning
then they ask you those questions early
and you figure out what the right
answers to those questions are so that's
how you solve the problem right there
now if it happens that for whatever
reason you're you didn't have the
opportunity to do that or you didn't do
it well enough or whatever the case may
be and now you start getting questions
on your
while you're briefing well first of all
if they ask you questions that you don't
have answers to then that that could
indicate that you're wrong actually you
could actually be wrong and not a lot of
leaders like to feel that way but you
should actually be happy that someone on
your team is pointing out something that
is gonna make the plan better as a whole
hmm so there's that and and it's really
easy if someone if you're in a brief and
someone brings up a point that you
didn't think of and it makes sense well
then you can implement that into the
plan okay so that now you might think
that it hurts your authority right to
say hey that's a good point Aiko I
didn't think of that let's implement you
might think or feel like that's gonna
make you look bad but the opposite is
actually true if I go no echo hey the
plans already completed you weren't
there for the planning so just be quiet
that's the guy that no one respects
that's the guy that's not looking good
as a leader that's the person that's
losing authority so you don't look weak
if you listen to members of the team
whether they're junior or senior it also
shows that you're incompetent if you
because because you missed a party
obviously the question is pertinent that
they asked or I should say if the
question is pertinent and it is a good
point then it shows that you miss an
important angle of the plan so open your
mind open your put your ego in check and
incorporate it in there now this can
also happen if there's something that
you know that you're right on but it's
something that you know that you're
right on if there's something like that
and you end this bleep maybe you get one
particular individual that keeps pushing
back and keeps pushing back and you
might have to in those cases say you
know what hey echo let me let me talk to
you after this brief is over and I'll
explain to you exactly while we're doing
it this way mm-hmm so that way doesn't
derail the brief because it might take a
longer explanation than you want to you
know for instance the typical SEAL
briefing was we try to keep it 50
minutes to an hour so if you've got if
you got to spend eight minutes pulling
up a different map and explaining some
detail
of the terrain to this guy that has a
protest to what you're saying you might
say hey listen when we get done with
this brief I'll pull your side let me
show you the let me show you the terrain
map and you can see exactly while we're
using this insertion route or whatever
the case may be so you can do that if
you have to and even then they might end
up having a point that you didn't see
and then you can say okay well I didn't
see that and now we have to give
everyone a quick rebreathing on some
change in the plan but again none of
this will happen if you bring your
subordinates in and you let them do
first of all let them do the planning
that's ideal let them come up with Lana
let echo come up with the plan I'm not
coming up the plan you go come up the
plan I'm gonna check with you and make
sure that the plan is going in the right
direction make sure it's not totally off
track and then you'll incorporate all
these things and I'll have a better view
of the plan I can stand back and be the
tactical genius as we talk about the
book extreme ownership like that's how
you do it hmm so that's the answer
well at least is an answer yeah maybe
other people have other answers seems to
make sense to me yeah that's that hard
it's hard right when you when you it's
one of those things you always got to be
conscious of when you have a plan or
whatever and someone for lack of a
better term pokes holes in it mm-hmm
like hey what about this what about this
and then you have that those two
elements that you got to keep in mind
where it's like the fact that it's your
plan and then the plan you know the
effectiveness I mean your emotional
attachment to the plan yeah you got to
keep the emotional attachment to the
plan in check versus the actual
effectiveness of the plan yeah and
people have a hard time doing that and
what's cool what's cool is once you
break away from that mindset then it's
really easier just to be and and
everyone just kind of knows oh yeah
chuckles you know he's got an open mind
he'll listen to you yeah as opposed to
someone that has a closed mind every
goes I'll you can't you can't give me
anything by this guy and he's gonna keep
he doesn't even help to point things out
because he won't listen and then guess
what you're using one brain versus 20
brains you know and more important than
the brainpower the perspective the
different perspectives is the guys in
the ground of the guys with the
technical knowledge and the tactical
knowledge they're gonna know things that
you don't know that's the way it is mmm
you can't know everything that they know
mm-hmm and so if you shut down all those
different perspectives you're looking at
something from one angle you know do you
see the whole complete picture when you
only look at something from one angle no
you don't know sir
use those other perspectives you know
check self-correcting machine mmm yes
getting let go of the ego the taking to
personal well personally when I was in
the SEAL Teams I called it the emotional
attachment to the plan
yeah because I see these people come up
with plans and they would be so addicted
to their own plan only because it was
their own plan not for any not for any
tactical or strategic or operational
reason whatsoever just like because they
thought of it yeah that's natural yeah
it's very natural yeah and there's some
element of of benefit to that right
because if you're passionate about your
plan and I'm passion about my plan as
long as we can eventually come to
compromise then we've put forth the best
idea because I don't want you to not be
passionate about your plan while you're
planning it I wasn't really coming up
with the best plan that you really
believed it and and it's interesting you
know you talk about poking holes right
poking holes in the plan and we all know
that it's very easy to sit back and poke
holes oh man and what I'm telling you to
do as a leader is to absolutely do that
not be a jerk no no and I'm talking as a
leader if I if I let you do the planning
then it's easy for me to sit back and
poke holes in the plan right which is
good it's good because we're gonna come
up with we're gonna fill those holes
once I poke the holes we're gonna fill
them we're gonna know that they're taken
care of also as a leader from a from a
perspective point you think aim
chocolate really knows what's going on
he was able to find these holes in the
plan the real reason I was able to find
him is just because I was not totally at
miniscule detail when you were I was up
at altitude relaxing looking around yeah
it's gonna I don't want to say cheating
such cheating but it is cheating is
cheating it's that much easier it's so
much easier to sit back and do it yeah
and let things go that way like when you
know when you watch a movie and you have
like some critique the movies
outstanding and then you have some
critique ahead I shouldn't have chose
that guy for that role or whatever you
mean while the movie is like
groundbreaking whatever you know so it's
easy to poke holes
the movie meanwhile like yeah yeah when
it's done you're all like poking holes
up the little imperfections do that all
the time make sense I dig it does it
happen with your videos probably Jack
anyway next question we have been
training jiu-jitsu for two months now we
started actually rolling a few weeks ago
from our knees on the mat like not
starting from standing basically I've
trained for an executed multi oh I've
trained for and executed multiple
marathons competed completed a number of
tough mudders trained hard in CrossFit
hiked biked swam and nothing compares to
the total mental and physical exhaustion
I feel after training jiu-jitsu how can
i combat this time train more
supplements just suck it up when I get
home I'm so beat in the next morning I
wake up feeling like I was hit by a bus
despite the exhaustion and still sucking
at it it's super fun okay so that's the
jujitsu that's the and okay so there's a
couple things here yes it's gonna take
some time you're gonna have to train you
train more your body will become
conditioned to it that's probably number
one number two is and this is so hard
for people to do relax it's really hard
it's really hard for people to do
especially when you first start out I
realized that the way you get to a point
when you start to relax is when you're
when when the capability of your
technique surpasses the capability of
your strength mm-hmm so if I know that I
can escape your choke attempt by holding
your hand and pulling your thumb and
pulling your arm off and that's what I
know that's what I'm gonna do when I
realize that I can use a technical
escape of swimming my arm in and then
placing my hips on the ground and then
scooting away from your choke I'll do
that instead but but until we figure out
the techniques all we have is
muscle so you the way you do is you you
just have to keep keep training and keep
training and sure you can try can people
actually when they try and relax do they
actually get you you tell me so I always
tell people like relax more like some
will say I just can't relax I'll be like
relax harder yeah but but it's hot it's
so hard for people to relax because
people say oh and I relaxed I just get
submitted yeah right yeah so but if you
relax you'll at least be aware of what's
happening and if you relax you can think
about the technical the technical
movement that you're supposed to do to
escape mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah I feel like
just like how you said though if you
don't know the move you're just gonna go
with what you know and it's gonna be the
spaz in one way or another you know if
you if a guy's on you MS like that's
never effective well cuz I cuz I'll all
go and say yes yes sometimes I have to
spaz and it Dean calls me out on that
alone well here's the thing good defense
you just spazzing well but yours has a
bigs more than a sprinkle of technique
you know that's the thing if true like
you and I told you this one time you
know how like if you say yeah you're
strong and that's kind of an insult in
jujitsu because it's like says yeah
you're strong but you don't have
technique it's kind of like that's what
you're implying but and I said this to
you one time I was like you have like
strength you're strong and you were like
not defensive but you're like no I have
technique or whatever and I was like
yeah I know that I was like shoot that
sounded bad
I mean you have technique we already
know that you've been training for 25
million years and you have good
technique but with that technique is
like a lot of strength in there like
when you um there's like stuff oh yeah
when like if you if I'll be inside
control on on top on you and you have
this like first so if your hands are in
the correct spot just to begin with yeah
that's to be and you can just kind of
get your leg in real easy
every single time like I can't talk
stuck it stop it and I'm not weak I'm
not weak but it's like the strength of
that move yeah is like it's unstoppable
and that's when I said it I was like you
you're like strong when you do a
technique it's like it's a strong thing
yeah and I would say though there's a
lot of ooh I would say it's probably 70%
technique in 30% strength which which
may confirm what you're saying you've
got 30% strength
yeah is still more than if someone has
70% technique yet they have only 10%
strength to get back at all yeah yeah
fully in even saying it's you know 70
percent technique 30% strength I mean
that's gonna vary from time from moment
to moment or experienced extreme so if
you're spazzing even that's gonna be a
spectrum like how much strength did you
use this technique kind of things you
can't suppose for a long time no your
videos be tired yes be gassed yeah yeah
so when I say you're strong here's the
thing the fact is you're strong
regardless of your technique or not you
can lift a lot of weights you're big try
grab like I I'll grab your wrist and
when you break the grip of the wrist
it's way more violent than the typical
person you're a strong person so there's
no denying that I know it sounds like an
insult whatever but nonetheless back to
the point yeah if so if you if you have
strength going in before you gain all
that technique over the over the years
just like how you said that's what
you're gonna use so the key is here I
think is to consciously and it's not
easy consciously focus on the technique
consciously like remember okay where am
i I'm in half guard right now because
you know like in the beginning when you
first learn the the positions you're
like half guard is real clear guard is
real clear when you start rolling around
you're halfway upside down maybe you're
twisting maybe your arms in the wrong
spot across your body or something you
kind of don't remember oh wait I'm in
half guard right now or I'm upside down
but I'm in you know I'm on his back
still whatever so you don't he doesn't
just stick in your mind what position
you're in but if you can do that then it
starts to get in getting routine so now
you after that you can figure out okay
am i safe here because that's why you
spaz that's why you you can't relax
because you don't know if you're safe or
not so you're just trying to move in and
get out of there or you know get a
submission hurry up before he does
something you know where this applies to
life this applies to life in when you're
interacting with other people and you
start to let's say you and I are having
a disagreement about something sure
right and
you start getting the upper hand on me
hmm and instead of me trying to use a
technique to get out all I do is go that
stupid echo you're done right I just
start interrupting you're cutting off
raising my voice I'm actually losing now
and I don't you know that but I'm
relying on brute force yeah as opposed
to technique now it could be also like
we talked about earlier could be that
I'm wrong and if instead of admitting
that I'm wrong or or taking like you're
saying relax and looking at the
technique and saying you know what echo
has a point here that I can't debate
against he's right and I'm wrong I need
to admit that same thing if you came up
with an idea for the plan and your idea
was better than mine or you had a point
that I needed to bring into the plan
unless like unless I can relax and
actually pay attention then I'm not
gonna be able to do that so that's how
that's one of the many ways when I
always talk about jujitsu applying to
life this is another example of where
hey if the argument starts to escalate
and you're using brute force to get out
of it you're not winning just like
you're not winning in jujitsu it's it
you're gonna gas out you're gonna you're
gonna lose yeah
don't use brute force yeah yeah not even
30% well maybe sometimes the other thing
is the other thing that's hard and it's
well it's it's attached to what you're
saying don't have death matches every
time yeah
all right don't it like you find a
partner and just be like okay let's try
and make sure that we're not using so
much strength I can roll with you or
with Dean or with Andy or whoever for a
long time and and it's a you know we're
sweating we're tired but we're not using
all this strength don't walking off the
mat with a with with thick burned-out
muscles yeah it's a difference more of a
cardio I would say then then a strength
thing when you get to a higher level
because you're you just movement its
movement that's happening you know when
do you know when someone's gonna
accomplish something and if you're gonna
fight it with muscle you're gonna you're
gonna end up losing yeah
and it goes back to the time thing where
the house Essen is it more time and
answers yeah it's more time because like
you you learn that
and again like where you knowing where
to be and where not to be where you're
safe and where you're not safe in
jiu-jitsu is a big deal so you know how
like okay let's say it's a and I know
this with you because let's say if I
pass your card I'm sorry you let me pass
your card I don't know you don't spaz
and like you know like in a tournament
where the guys like really trying hard
to let you settle in guard and so that's
a different scenario of course but um
you never do that you it's like you get
to a point past your guard once you kind
of get there you just you settling
you're you're kind of relaxing because
you it seems like anyway that you know
you're not in danger for a submission so
that's kind of really where the focus is
it's not the fact that he passes my card
oh no that's terrible it's not that it's
okay now what technique do I need to
implement to keep myself safe and the
more you know about jujitsu the more you
realize it doesn't take a huge amount of
energy to implement that technique it's
usually just like an arm position or
make sure his hip is like over there and
not over here and that's kinda that's it
that's pretty much it but if you don't
know that you're like oh man you're
using your whole body to get out of
there kind of thing and that's that's
when you're leaving no reserves in a
military perspective in the military
you're always supposed to keep your
reserves as long as you can oh yeah
you're just you've ended a lot of serves
trying to spaz out get out of a dominant
position you're also attacking a
dominant position when you're spazzing
to try and get out yeah you're you're
just going crazy trying to get out of
this confirmed position I mean across
the side or the mount those are
positions that are really sure there's a
transitional time when you should
definitely spaz to try and get out once
that's surpassed well now you're just
you're just expending energy yeah so
defense ladies check your diet too if
you're like really sore and everything
make sure you're getting enough protein
make sure to get enough fat make sure
you're getting maybe get some get some
super krill or some or some joint
warfarin or both because the your body
needs it so just other things to try and
put off that soreness and the pain yeah
all right yeah all that twisting yeah
there's definitely you know well yeah
it's hard on your joints yeah work out
you know they get a workout that you
won't
beginning doing other stuff yeah unless
yeah you know construction or something
like that same thing you're gonna get
joint stuff that's how but yeah keep it
supposed to be fun the death matches
though death matches yeah white belt
death matches yeah probably I would
estimate forty percent of all injuries
in jiu-jitsu come from white belt death
matches is that you think that's a good
number
yeah if not hot iron yeah full-on yeah
yeah next question you talk about you
talk about empathy and perspective and
building relationships as a leader but I
look at leader a leader like Steve Jobs
who's known for his hostile attitude
toward people isn't that being default
aggressive like you talk about if I'm
more naturally that type of leader
should I go with it if it worked for
Steve Jobs shouldn't it work for me so
that's a good question and I haven't
actually read the book about Steve Jobs
and I think there's probably more than
one but there's the one that's real
popular real thick and someone gave it
to me and I have it and I will someday
but I haven't read it yet and I've heard
it's really good and all that and I that
being said I've I've heard the same
things about you know Steve Jobs the
leadership style and he was real
tyrannical and I pulled a couple things
here just from well here we go
in his book about jobs time at next and
returned to Apple the second coming of
Steve Jobs
Alan Deutsch 'men described jobs rough
treatment of his underlings he would
praised as a quote he would praise and
inspire them often in very creative ways
but he would also resort to intimidating
goading berating belittling and even
humiliating them so and there's another
article by Ronald regio who's a PhD in
psychology and the article came from
Psychology Today and it says he was
obsessively controlling and given to
fits of rage throwing tantrums and
yelling at employees and board members
he could tear down someone's ideas or
the person himself in a public display
some have said he took credit for others
ideas and his confidence led to a sort
of over-the-top arrogance so the guys
kind of tyrannical one time when they
were putting together the MobileMe
application and it wasn't working well
and jobs told the team that was putting
it together you when it wasn't working
you've tarnished Apple's reputation you
should hate each other for having let
each other down so okay so first of all
let's look at the fact that you've heard
me say this before that people's
strengths are their weaknesses and their
weaknesses can be their strengths so in
Steve Jobs case obviously some of this
stuff some of his weaknesses that we're
talking about here were also strengths
because he was totally beyond driven
right he was completely obsessed with
with doing good and all that and and he
pressed toward his vision extremely hard
he was relentless in trying to make
things happen and again those are very
positive characteristics if you got
someone that's really driven and they're
driven to the point of almost being
obsessed and you you take that and those
are kind of good characteristics but
when they go too far this is why it's
dichotomy this is a balance of
leadership right when you go too far you
become a tyrannical leader which is not
good it's not good for a team and it's
and it's and a team that is subjected to
that kind of attitude will not perform
as well as a unified team period period
so the guy was clearly hostile and at
the same time clear clearly he was one
of the most successful business leaders
in history right so would you look at
him and say okay well maybe I should be
that way maybe I should be a tyrannical
leader and I would say to that no you do
not get to do that and here's why let's
look at some other characteristics that
Steve Jobs had first of all he was
perhaps the foremost technological
visionary in the history of the world
right I mean he had a vision of
technology that very few people in the
history in the world of had and I will
go a little bit more narrow I think he
understood things on a note another
level when it came to technology that
the part of how human beings would
interact with technology that's the part
that I think he really had just
incredible vision for he realized like
oh these people won't want a computer in
their house and they'll want it to
reflect the way they live and they're
gonna want music in their pocket they're
gonna want all of the music in their
pocket and they're gonna want a phone
that can do it you know he had this
vision of how people would interact with
technology that I don't think too many
people have hmm so so that's number one
number two he had a phenomenal feel for
design right for design and how to merge
form and function together in in an in
an aesthetically pleasing in an
oftentimes stunning way if you look at
the design and that's uncommon
especially for someone to have that feel
for design and still have a massively
technical background right so so that
again we're making a person that's like
1% of 1% of 1% already on top of that he
got into business his business at the
right time in the right place he had the
right background on top of that the guy
could speak well the guy was very
articulate right he was very articulate
with his vision if you do you watch his
keynote speeches that he would give at
the whatever it is when they have the
Apple Convention what's that thing
called the Apple come in yeah they have
that thing well he'd get up on stage and
he'd talk about something and he would
articulate that and he would do it with
real clarity and he was very convincing
and he was very captivating and people
were you know they'd say apples a cult
mmm they'd follow that guy so he had all
those skills those world-class skills
and I'm not using that term lightly I'm
talking world-class skills and then
they're all those
class skills are combined together into
one package one human being and there
you got you got Steve Jobs so he's got
all those advantages and then on top of
that he's had some luck along the way
right he had some luck in his timing and
his upbringing and in the exposures that
he got and being exposed to computer
programming and those things back in the
day was rare and he got lucky and having
that unfold from so he had all these
things going for him that helped propel
him and his company to the top so now if
you're thinking maybe you should use his
leadership style the the questions that
you should ask yourself is are you a
one-in-a-billion the technological
visionary or visionary of any kind the
answer that is likely no and if you
think it's yes maybe you should check
your ego a little bit then you have to
ask yourself do you have an eye for
design an artistic eye for design like
like da Vinci or Michelangelo if you
have that you probably don't if you
think you have that maybe you should
check your ego again are you a gifted
speaker and storyteller and can you
convey your vision with total clarity
two big giant groups broad groups of
people and if you think you can do that
again you should check your ego can you
count on luck or do you want to count on
luck to close the gaps in some of those
other areas so if you could do all those
things if you answered yes a hundred
percent to all those questions and okay
maybe you can get away with being a kind
of leader that Steve Jobs was but if
you're a normal person if you're a
normal human being then maybe you should
try and be a good leader and maybe you
should be a leader that builds
relationships and forms cohesive teams
and coalition's that help you drive your
mission forward despite the ups and
downs of whatever business you're in so
that's it Steve Jobs had a lot of other
things that made him successful
yeah and leadership and he I've got to
eventually read the book but he clearly
had some people around him that that
utilized that skill the skills that he
did had and have and moved and helped
move him forward right other people at
the company other people early and in
Apple we saw that hey you know what this
guy he might be a little bit hard to
deal with but he's got some things that
we won't find anywhere else
so let's prop them up and let's move
forward yeah and that's that's the way
it works yeah I think they call that
survivorship bias where like you see oh
you see a successful guy in you yeah
yeah he did it that way so let's do it
that way um but yeah you you kind of
don't see all the other factors or
whatever
almost like you if you really think
about it if Steve Jobs were to be like
in these tyrannical laser when if you
were to be less like that maybe there
would be more saying but he was so
strong in these other areas that it kind
of like mitigated the effects you know
there's there's businesses that are
successful because they're a successful
business model and they have really bad
leadership yeah and even that kinda
thing that yep even the bad leadership
doesn't it's the the model is so good
yeah which is a little bit contrary
because you know I would say leadership
the most important thing on the
battlefield but in the business world if
you have a phenomenal idea then you can
you can be successful on that idea alone
now that is that is a unicorn that is
one of those rare things where you have
something that's that incredibly
different and stands out from the crowd
so much that it's gonna be successful no
matter what you know when the when the
early gyms MMA type gyms if you had one
you were successful didn't matter what
kind of leader you were because you add
you had it and and now there's
competition if you're not if you don't
good leadership and you're not putting
forth a good product amongst all the
competitors you're gonna have problems
yeah you're gonna have problems with it
yeah and the more I kind of listen to
you and life the more I realize that
even then the like it's almost like you
have to have a minimum
level of leadership like you don't be
have to be perfect if you have the one
of these situations where the product of
the business model no good but still
even your leadership can mess that oh
yeah you can absolutely because you yeah
like you're in a situation where like
now no one wants to work for you now
what oh yeah good nice MMA gym you don't
have any you got to work there yeah you
know the whole time and you can't you
know so it's gonna kind of fall apart
after a while so maybe like it in the
beginning it'd be good but it'll fall
apart because he you sure for sure and
you you can see that who's the guy that
just got removed from uber I'd have to
go into D I have to really drill down on
it but the CEO of uber got removed and
you know the business models awesome
yeah and they still remove the CEO why
because there's there's issues there
yeah yeah and so well it's a great
business model but we still need good
leadership yeah so yeah like you like it
I'm basically confirming what you just
said the good business model will get
you to a certain level but then to get
to the next level and you're gonna need
leadership and that's why because it's
the most important thing on the
battlefield so what the moral don't
necessarily be tyrannical little in fact
don't be straight up so radical yeah
don't be and I'm not saying that there's
not times where you have to have a
little tyrannical flair because there
there may be times where you need to
where you need to flare up a little bit
yeah but it should be rare yeah it
should be rare the problem is it becomes
a crutch for people and then they just
continue to do it more and more and more
and more and then doesn't work it's like
it's kind of like drugs to the like when
you like when you flare up on someone
and you win or whatever you know you
kind of like it works yeah I worked and
you kind of lay it feels good feels
powerful mmm so I think some people
that's how you know so they'll do it and
it'll work and they'll be like yeah I
don't need that little yeah and what's
even worse is like when you win that's
where you you learn from someone that's
what you saw and then do you do it and
you don't work for me to and I'll have
to be is treat people bad and be a jerk
and yell and
the my subordinates will do what I tell
them to do and they will write the
subordinate will if you bark at them and
scream at them they're gonna do what you
say at the moment mm-hmm
the problem is what kind of team of you
built that's the problem yeah what does
that support they're gonna do when
you're not there yeah they're gonna do
everything they can to to cut corners
and and really they don't care about
they don't care about you
they don't want to do a good job for you
yeah so when you're not there they're
not gonna do a good job for you yeah so
you get addicted to yelling and
screaming but it doesn't work in the
broad sense of what you're trying to
make happen
yeah apart next question I'm 26 years
old I'm currently an undercover
detective I've recently been told that
I'm being promoted to sergeant over our
departments Investigations Division I've
been the youngest person to hold a
position in our departments history all
the guys I'll be in charging of our much
older some in their late 40s
how do I as a younger leader lead them
how do you demand and earn respect from
an older group I'm ready for the job and
know what the job entails but I'm
nervous to lead a group with nine people
that are all older than me so I'm I've
answered this question over and over
again and I'm gonna do a quick job of it
here just because people may not they
have gone back and listened to all the
other podcasts but you have listened the
answer is always the same and it's
always the same whether you're a young
person leading old persons whether
you're an old person leading young
people whether you're a woman leading
men a men leading man leading women
whether you're coming in from a
different department into a new
department that you don't know anybody
whether you're going into a thing that
you don't have experience it's like all
the same basically what it is you're
going into a leadership position yeah
that's what it is be humble listen take
advice build relationships keep your ego
in check also that one of the reasons I
pulled the did pull this course not easy
like how do you demand respect well the
answer is you don't demand respect
and if you don't if you do demand
respect you'll get anything but respect
from people mm-hmm so so get that out of
your head you earn respect and how do
you earn respect you respect them in
this case you
back there experience you respect their
knowledge you respect it they've been
doing it for a long time you have
respect for it and when you show respect
for them they're gonna respect you back
now none of this means be passive hmm
right
this doesn't mean cower down no you you
still have to lead you still have to
step up but it does mean be humble be
open-minded be proactive listen ask
questions ask for opinions
de-centralized all aspects of operations
including the planning which we already
talked about and then with all those
things set a high standard and then the
final and most important well I don't
know it's equally important I'd say work
harder than everyone else and expect
nothing in return
mm-hmm that's it yeah that's it you're
the boss
you better be you better be at work
before everyone and you better be
leaving work after everyone and that's
how you develop a reputation of being a
hard worker and being a hard worker in
its own right Garner's respect from most
people there's there's a fraction of
losers that are like Oh echo he works so
much it's it's so lame like know why cuz
I'm making them look bad or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah like there's a small
fraction of people that that might think
that way yeah but but no you work hard
you you put in the time you put in the
effort you study you read what you're
supposed to read you get the
professional knowledge that you're
supposed to get you don't impose that on
people yeah you have it because you're
your book knowledge when you start off
in this situation your book knowledge
isn't as strong as the experienced guys
in this case you know in the in the law
enforcement the guys that have been in
the streets they know stuff that you
don't know yeah so you study what you
can but you keep an open mind so you can
listen to what their experience says
yeah don't impose on them when you say
don't impose it on them does that mean
don't impose them like make them it's
like them echo Section four to alpha of
the
the document says that we're supposed to
use this methodology when we do this
yeah you should know that methodology
you should understand why that
methodology is important but if you say
hey jogo we don't do it that way and
here's why I shouldn't I'm telling you
by the book it's by the book now if it's
by the book because it's there's an
ethical reason ok well then that make
sense but it's by the book because
that's what the book says but by the
book
yeah yeah or you know the guy who's like
who works extra hard but he kind of in a
way throws it in everyone's face how are
you that that's that's an important
thing it's a very important piece don't
you don't step on people's toes with
this stuff yeah that's wrong yeah don't
do that check X wish chuckle I'm
extremely extremely driven and have high
expectations for myself and my team
it appears that now I may have pushed
them too hard and they're developing
negative attitudes I feel like you're
going to say play the game and develop
relationships with them but should I
really just ignore Who I am
should I try to be someone different
than myself yeah well you call that
question person whoever asked this
question you called I that's exactly
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna say you
need to play the game look at what your
current path has done look at what you
the real you look what it's done real
you has created a negative attitude with
all your team that's the real you so is
that what you want to perpetuate
creating negative attitudes against your
deal with your team and by the way
they're just getting started
and if you think negative if you think
you're gonna keep acting the same way
and the negative attitudes are gonna
somehow miraculously turn positive
that's not happening they're gonna get
more negative yeah so when people have
negative attitudes I saw somebody quoted
this the other day on on social medias
on Twitter someone would you know know
the quote was like no no no it's not my
fault when nice my subordinates have a
bad attitude or something like that and
about a bunch of people responded you
should read the book extreme
because it absolutely is your fault it
is your fault if your team has a bad
attitude it's your fault you're the
leader you own the attitude if their
attitude is bad then it's then it's
actually your fault now this is not to
say that you can't have a bad apple on
the team that's completely possible and
who's responsible for getting rid of the
bad apples you are you're the boss
because the fact the matter is you might
have a bad apple on your team you might
even have two bad apples on your team
you don't have 14 bad apples on the team
when you have 14 battles that apples on
the team guess who the problem is it's
you so here's what you do a little
little tactical advice try and get some
perspective from them trying to
understand where they're coming from
what challenges they face what's pulling
them off track and when you do this you
kind of take ownership of it in your
approach so you said hey guys I I
realize I don't think I'm really seeing
things from your point of view and I
need to because I'm here to support you
and without you performing well then we
fail so I think I need to do a better
job of supporting you and I can only do
that if I know what your issues are so I
can do my best to get them fixed so what
can I do better to help you
alright so now they're gonna start
telling you all here's where there's
this problem there's that problem and
then what you do is you listen to their
problems you actually listen to problems
you don't say quit complaining no you
actually listen to their problems and
then you actually see what you can do to
mitigate their issues and as you do that
guess what's happening you're actually
forming a bond you're actually forming
into a team because you're working
together to solve issues again I it
sounds really simple right
but clearly here's someone asking this
question now again like if you have some
members of the team that are that are
actual negative complaining whiners then
you might have to get rid of them and
and that's part of being a leader is
knowing when you have to get rid of
someone
you know I sometimes people they they
take the extreme ownership attitude and
they say you know what I'm the leader I
own everything
I'm extreme ownership and if someone's
not performing well then that's my fault
yeah that's my fault I need to coach a
more I need to I need to do it's my
fault that my team member is not doing
well and that's correct it is your fault
it's your responsibility to train them
coach a mentor um and do whatever else
you can do to fix them but at the end of
the day if they still are not competent
at their task and you've done everything
you can it's you're responsible to get
rid of them that is also a part of
ownership so yeah like I'll have someone
complaining that they've got oh this you
know one of my team leaders like they're
talking about their subordinate team
leaders a little more like this this
guy's just a bad leader mm-hmm why is he
still here they owe your team that team
isn't doing well because they have a bad
leader whose fault is that
mmm who's the leaders fault no it's your
fault you're in charge of the leader
yeah it's ridiculous so back to the
original question your whatever you
called it you're who you actually are is
not working well he probably is thinking
he's a Steve Jobs type a we got to do
this but it's not working
and he's not in a unicorn business model
that's still making a ton of money
regardless so what does he have to do
play the game build the relationships
see the perspective of your team so that
you can actually form a team you know be
a better leader that's basically what
I'm saying yeah so they in it's
interesting the you know what they call
framing you know you frame something
something a certain way to make it kind
of sound a certain way whatever so you
say extremely driven and have high
expectations for myself and my team it
appears that now I may have pushed them
too hard and they're developing negative
attitudes so having extreme being
extremely driven and having high
expectations doesn't equal equal driving
them too hard so they develop that
negative those are two
different you know you can still be
exchanged so yeah you can absolutely
have extremely high expectations you can
be driving extremely hard and you can
still have a incredibly positive
attitude with our team yeah no doubt
yeah good point so and then it gets
equated into that's just who I am
so he just kind of put it all into one
ball and without one there's no other
kind of situation it's just not how it
is no so apparently you might be
committed he might be committed to being
all of these things and that's who I am
and that's kind of it you know kind of
thing and I think that's like the
mistake planning people make we say this
a lot where people will be like hey I'm
just straightforward you know take me
take it or leave it kind of thing and be
like okay but you're gonna in your case
loose you know and you're in your
situation that's the big piece is that
in their case they're gonna lose yeah so
let me ask you this question if you're
so driven and you have such high
expectations that you want to win so bad
but the way you're performing as a human
being and as a leader is gonna make you
lose then what are you supposed to do
you change the way you behave you leave
a better leader yeah that's what you do
yes sir so you take and this is total
speculation on my part but you keep kids
so this equation that we're presented
with it's being extremely driven keep
that high expectations keep that pushing
your team hard keep that I would say to
harden that's gonna be a judgement call
from day to day for sure um but there's
a part in here that's more implied that
you're being an somewhere in
here you've been a so how about you take
out that part take out the bean the
part and then keep everything
else see how that goes yeah cuz you kind
of know when you're being a dick I'm
saying unless you're like not being
honest with yourself there are there's
some people that don't there's some
feeling don't get it there's some people
who don't get it all right because it's
like you know how like when you don't
like people they just can't step outside
of themselves and be like okay that to
me I wouldn't care kind of thing and
like bro
well you know you're not me and well I'm
not you yeah yeah you're right they
can't attach yeah absolutely people that
don't know they're socially incapable of
receiving you know clues social clues
yeah social cues from people yeah you
know they don't see the look in their
face when they're talking to them yeah
that's true I mean I'm thinking of like
three girls yeah also that then that
would go back to what you're saying how
you say get input from them yes yes so
you gotta kind of yeah yeah you do it's
a solvable problem oh this is a very
solvable problem and I've seen people
solve this problem I've helped people
solve this exact problem and the weird
thing is they think and it's part ago
but it's also part they're just I don't
person they think they're doing a great
thing like they think that they're
driving when they're everything that
they're doing in their mind they're just
awesome for being super pushing so hard
it's just the way I am and all that
stuff and they think it's awesome but
again if you want to win so bad then you
have to play the game you won't win by
abusing people you won't win with a team
anyways it won't it won't happen yeah
it's no use being the best dancer if
you're not invited on the dance floor
actually that problem is so solvable
that you could this is possible where
you could just show just that much like
more know caring or respect just that
much respect and do for like two weeks
yeah just the idea that just the fact
that you're doing it now people will be
like hey where's this thing here's the
thing if a person has an ego which this
person could very well have a big ego
because that's why they have these high
expectations and that's why they're so
driven because they just they if they
have that kind of ego that's the person
that you can't help because if they just
look at the team and say those guys
should be hard workers yeah
those guys aren't working as hard as me
they're not as focused as I am yeah they
don't care as much as I do so to
everyone else on the team has a problem
yeah but but I'm perfect and you can't
you know look at how driven I am look at
how focused I am look at how high my
expectations are of myself but if you
can't here's another thing if your team
cannot relate to your expectations like
they don't even they don't even see them
as realistic or achievable or anything
well good what could are your
expectations yeah what good are they
they're not any good no good they don't
make any sense next wash dear Jocko I've
been watching some of you youtube links
with great interests must be a
subscriber to the YouTube channel yeah
I'm sure you're extremely busy but I
have question which if you have time I
would greatly appreciate your reply I
have taken thirty light opening yeah
very much so
okay let me incorporate that approach
I mean I've taken up BJJ jiu-jitsu
recently in London in the UK so uh so a
beginner I know you're a great advocate
of the system but my basic question is
your opinion does it truly relate to
real-life fight situations I'm a man now
approaching my mid forties in pretty
good shape that I'm looking to focus on
a martial art that would help me if I
ever need to defend myself or my family
I love the discipline and humility of
BJJ and as a workout I know and I know
the philosophy of BJJ is that most
fights end up on the ground and it's
here that BJJ excels but what of the
other guys or what of the other guys who
might be standing around ready to battle
bottle you or kick you in the head once
you're grappling on the ground etcetera
again this is a question that first of
all we I've answered this a lot of times
sure but I'll answer it one more time it
jiu-jitsu is the best place to start you
should also learn boxing wrestling kick
boxing this is all in discipline equals
freedom Field Manual so if you get that
book this will be laid out for you very
well does so so yes that's what you
should start studying with this guy
mid-40s needs wants to learn something
yes start with jiu-jitsu does it relate
to real a real life situations yes it
does it absolutely does I've been in
them it's extremely effective and you
can see that over and over again
speaking of YouTube you can see how
effective jiu-jitsu is in real fights
now it's important to remember that for
self-defense the grappling arts in
general should be used primarily to get
away it to avoid going to the ground
right like when you bring up oh well
what if there's other people that might
be there you you should why are you on
the ground
jiu-jitsu will give you the best
opportunity to get up off the ground
that's what it gives you and then you
can get away from the people that are
getting ready to submit stick you with a
bottle smashed bottle or getting ready
to kick you in the head if you don't
know jiu-jitsu guess what you're doing
you're on the ground and you're getting
kicked in the head and you're getting
stabbed with a bottle that's why you
trained you Jitsu so you can get up off
the ground not so you can take someone
to the ground because by the way and
I've said this before if your goal is to
punch me and you're standing at a
punching distance or a striking distance
for me I can just run away that's my
self-defense I can get away from you mmm
so that's why we train jiu-jitsu that
that's the primer that's why you should
start with it because otherwise I'm just
gonna get away from you if you're not
grant if once you grab me though I can't
get away from you anymore now I have to
be able to handle myself that's why I
know you did too so I can handle myself
once you've grabbed me if you're not
grabbing me I can just get away from it
and run away from you mm-hmm if you
don't want to run away because it's
gonna hurt your pride well then guess
what that's that's why you train all the
time I mean now we go back and forth and
we can talk about all the negative
things that will happen if you get into
a street fight like the fact that you
can get hurt you can get stabbed you can
get shot you can get sued you can get
arrested you can ruin your life you can
do all these horrible things can happen
if you get in a street fight so so so
that's why my advice to you is to avoid
street fights that's what you do and by
the way that's why you work on your
awareness that's why you make your your
your your wife and your children aware
of what's going on around them to pay
attention to what's happening in the
street it's the one thing that was
interesting when I was in Australia and
I was in a nice part of Australia
there's an I was talking to some people
about it you know there's just a very
relaxed atmosphere mmm where I was I was
standing in a very nice part of
Australia there's a very relaxed
atmosphere when you're in America
there's a heightened atmosphere there's
a heightened awareness you have to have
and depending on where you are and it's
the same thing I'm sure in Australia I
went to the nice part I'm sure you could
go to some some tough areas where you
better be more aware of what's happening
but teach your kids because some kids
don't know the difference maybe you
don't even know the difference of what
to look out for what kind of people you
need to watch out for in the street so
work on that and then yes train and a
beer in UK and of course I've said this
before if you are truly in a situation
where you feel threatened on a regular
basis well then what you need is a
firearm because if someone's going to
attack you with a knife or with a bottle
or themselves having a gun the only
jujitsu isn't gonna help you mmm
boxing is gonna help you Escrima is not
gonna help you if someone has a gun so
yeah and and by the way oh yeah if
you're in a knife fight and you know
some of scream of that will help you but
what if the other guy is better than you
what what if there's two of them the
minute you put two people against one
the odds of winning are it just
extremely low extremely low does it
happen
yes it happens can you knock someone out
yes you can that's why you trained
boxing so yes again train some jiu-jitsu
start there and go and keep going and
don't stop yeah yeah it seems like this
question always comes from a place where
they just assume all these things and
those things are I'm gonna choose to get
in a fight with someone bring it to the
grind in the mid
the street or in your club I don't know
wherever wherever there's potential
other attackers with bottles and in
kicks to the head and so all these
things you just assume kind of like yeah
you take jiu-jitsu now you can go to the
club and get in fights and win all the
time it's kind of like that's kind of
where the question is coming from where
how you said yeah it allows you to get
up and it's so basic it allows you to
control your situation your fight
scenario yeah more yes and I would even
say it allows you a lot more to control
it because even if even if you do take
it let's say you take it to the circus I
meant more by a little bit more than
nothing yeah no yeah I'm saying a lot
more because really when you think I'm
in and I try to granted them yeah even
like at a beginner level so let's say
okay if you choose to engage with
someone in some kind of fight right it's
up to you how heavy you want to take
that fight you want to go to ten you go
to ten you want to go to just one you
can go to one so if you wind up on the
ground which is the worst place to be if
you don't know anything on the ground
yeah and that's the site from how you
say if the guy's a gun and shoots you
that's a deer you're talking about
that's not even a fight scenario that's
you know so you wind up in the girl it's
a gunfight yeah
if you know boxing you're gonna have
almost no control over that scenario
yeah yeah your boxing is your boxing is
not worthless marginalise dual sex but
it's heavily marginalized yeah heavily
marginalized yeah same thing with you
know kickboxing and whatever so there's
that if you know jiu-jitsu just a little
bit of jiu-jitsu if you're on the ground
you have control of the fight more
depending on your level whatever so if
you if you're at that point still facing
a threat of someone with a bottle or
kicks to the head or whatever while
you're on the ground compare if you know
you get to versus if you don't know did
you see your still save it way more
control way more so meanwhile like the
box situation or current situation
whenever it's gonna going to be less
effective in controlling your situation
now if you don't look at it like that
like if you look at it like okay this
guy's squaring up to me now I want to
mess him up as quickly as I can then
okay you know like you can do boxing and
just take it to ten but you don't have
the option of taking it from one two
three or nothing like yeah but the other
thing is like it's hard to knock someone
else it's hard to knock someone I yeah
does it happen yeah it does happen and
it can happen to you too it can happen
to you too it's but it's hard to knock
someone out and it's it's risky as soon
as you start saying okay you and I are
gonna just trade punches there's a risk
from for both of us there's a risk for
me the assurance of me being able to
handle the situation the way I want it
to go by closing the distance with you
getting control and getting a hold of
you if I'm trained and you're not yeah
you're you're you're done yeah you're
done right that's the way it works yeah
and then even then that's like if you
choose for this guy to be done so if
your if your sole purpose is to keep
yourself safe yeah you could just put
the guy to sleep and walk away yeah or
gently lambie like mount I'm not even
hurt I'm not gonna put him to sleep
nothing mount you see a guy you can see
the guy coming with a bottle or whatever
way more if you know jiu-jitsu so well
there's the whole thing of when you're
just used to the physical contact you
the the body's clashing and you know
grappling less shock yeah so yeah
trained jiu-jitsu trained boxing
wrestling kickboxing and then of course
now people will be like what about judo
yes trained judo what about Zombo yes
trained yeah what else what else
do I need to cool
what about Krav Maga sure let's train it
yeah yeah train everything yeah I'm down
at the Starwood jiu-jitsu well you said
on a real general level it's the most
critical things like when someone gets
ahold of you like yeah and you put this
into perspective a while ago when you
were like yeah if someone wants to fight
you walk away for runaway easier but
even said all these scenarios you can
run away you're going you want to keep
yourself safe yeah you don't be there
the best thing to do to avoid the the
getting punched falling on the curb of
dying getting stabbed getting kicked
getting
stabbed with a bottle getting arrested
getting lawsuit getting all those things
happening the best thing to do run away
walk away leaf fully and then you said
but what happens when you can't run away
because I grabbed there you have it yeah
so yeah so it seems like yeah I'm gonna
train boxing so I can do self-defense no
you want to fight somebody that's what
you want to do you want to punch people
in the face it all box no jujitsu I mean
yeah I mean but boxing is a is a skill
that every buddy should have not
everyone good people should have because
there's two critical things on that that
you learn from boxing is how to punch
people on how to avoid getting punched
yeah and how to keep your guard up right
those are important those are really
important skills to have yeah fully but
what what I mean is if you're starting
from nothing and you're like okay I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna choose to
address my self-defense you situation
you have a fantasy that you saw a guy on
YouTube that was clearly a box or knock
up knock out two people in a street
fight and you're like that's what I'm
gonna do yeah yeah that's what you
actually watched was a guy that was a
Golden Gloves boxer yeah who was sober
knockout two drunk idiots and guess what
a Golden Gloves boxer will do that if
you ever sparred with a Golden Gloves
boxer they're freakin good they're
freakin good look they're there they're
there
you know like a black belt in boxing
yeah and they will knock out two drunk
guys all day long yeah yeah it's weird
too because the cut if one of those if a
third drunk guy or even that first drunk
guy grabs a hold of the boxer yeah and
just and gets him to the ground the
boxer is gonna be in trouble you know
that's the way it is we and this isn't
like my thoughts this is fact this is
like I talked about some discipline in
the Field Manual it's like look there's
no conjecture it's not like I wonder
what would happen no we know what
happens we know what happens when two
people fight and and you can watch all
the different various types of styles
going at it and you can watch what
happens and sure you can find the rare
video where hey this boxer knocks out a
couple drunk people or or
even hey the boxer knocks out the guy
does that happen yes it can absolutely
happen that's why you train boxing do ya
next question
I've not been working out regularly
regularly for several years now
obviously I'm fat and lazy but I want to
get after it
so the question is should I go all-in
level 9 destruction maximum madness or
ease into it at level 3 cruising
addition all right well listen there's a
couple different approaches you know
when I hear this first of all you you
don't want to get hurt right and you
also don't want to make yourself try and
do things that are so hard and so
painful that you can't do it repeatedly
yeah so if you just destroy yourself Mac
what do you say do you destroy yourself
level 9 destruction maximum madness but
then you can't work out for two more
weeks well guess what what you do in the
mean no let's say realistically you got
Dom's thumbs sure right delayed onset
muscle soreness let's say you did so
many burpees that your legs you couldn't
sit down without your legs being in pain
so now don't so you take so you take
three days four days have you ever had
Dom's so bad that you took four days off
no okay let's say you take three days
off mmm
what did you do during those three days
did you hold the line did you stay on
the path or were you eating Cheetos yeah
that's what you were doing so if you
destroy yourself to where you can't stay
on the path that's not good you want to
stay on the path I think doing something
that you can handle or maybe something
just beyond what you can handle every
single day is more important so going at
a level not not cruising level not level
three but let's let's find a solid level
five where you can you're pushing
yourself I read a thousand words a day
when I'm writing and let you do the
equivalent of that right the reason I
read because if I said okay I'd do it
tonight I just said today I just have to
write five thousand words that's five
hours yeah will do I have five hours
today no I don't I can squeeze out fifty
two minutes though and get
thousand words written that I can do so
that's that's what I think you need to
do you need to get consistent if you
bite off more than you chew then you can
chew your you you might very well choke
on it so tons so don't do that so pick
something realistic do people say that
that was the first time I heard it so if
you bite off more than you can chew you
might choke on it did you make that up
where you get that from somewhere I
think well I just I don't know if I
think I made it up
it's good but I'm sure I like be like no
this guy said it in 1978 yeah there's
the beauty of it okay so pick something
realistic like something that you can
handle and then get after it then the
other thing here is he doesn't talk
about his diet at all and that's clearly
equally important and you have to change
your diet if you're gonna change your
life and you're gonna change your health
so stop eating sugar stop eating
processed foods no more soda and juices
and no more Gatorade just to start with
or whatever it is whatever that it is
that you're doing whoever asked this
question whatever you know what you're
doing if you're eating donuts and wrong
don't don't even know that's any more
stop to stop eating those get rid of
that sugar sweetness craving thing yeah
and then just keep making your diet
cleaner and cleaner as time goes by yeah
so that's what I think is there any time
that it's good because sometimes I think
it's good when people do go like all
right man I'm done yeah
like i whatever happened they went up
the staircase and they they got all
tired and they say you know what I'm
done yeah it starts tomorrow but I think
in those cases most the time who was it
who was it that we were talking to
talking to someone someone that they are
I was talking to someone that their
first thing they try to do they couldn't
do at all mmm like they tried to run
three miles and they were like you know
what can't do it you can't run three
miles oh it might have been that guy
there's a guy that's losing a bunch of
weight on the
interwebs oh yeah that's what it is I
think he's down in Texas but he's trying
to lose a lot of weight and the first
time he went to try to go for run didn't
happen enough didn't happen so he had to
just run less I had to just walk
actually it starts long so yeah you you
start with what you can do but there is
a little bit of there is there is I
would try I would say this keep this one
in in the back of your mind there is the
whole thing of like you know what I'm
changing my life right now you go home
you get the garbage can out you bring it
into the kitchen and throw away the
Twinkies you throw away the pop-tarts
you throw away the that you pour the the
crappy soda down the drain and you get
on the path and you just don't look back
yeah that's a good thing to do - yeah
but again if that person's 300 pounds
they're not gonna be able to do I mean
they're gonna push themselves yeah they
could push themselves too hard yeah so
you just got to be careful yeah see and
then it's funny when when I'm kind of
looking at the question I'm like well
obviously you want to start slow right
obviously but then you hear about these
guys just like how you said they just
they throw everything away they were
like I'm a different person right I
think I think we're crossing streams
here or I am
there's diet and then there's like
workout yeah because diet you can pretty
much go cold turkey today yeah it lits
and you may or may not be able to relate
to this but if you cook straight extreme
on your diet like all of a sudden you're
hit with these the byproducts of
changing your diet especially if you'd
like like Mountain Dew every single day
and you just all of a sudden boom stop
doing a bunch right you'll go through
stuff that you might not expect like the
craving li-ion free and minimal doses of
mountain yeah no yeah basically
no I'm gonna say no just stop thinking
about dude you don't need
yeah and I dig in you're gonna go
through withdrawals right yeah through
caffeine with Charles and sugar
withdrawals you're gonna get the the the
keto flu and all those things are gonna
happen and it's gonna be rough but yeah
but don't just say it like that it's
gonna be rough work that's all bro
seriously if you go into that and you
experience these types of things and
it's gonna apply to everything by the
way any big change that you make where
you you have to deprive yourself of
these bad things that you've become kind
of addicted to or whatever you're gonna
go through all kinds of changes and that
goes for worked out too by the way
cuz like just the soreness alone oh dang
I expected the soreness oh I'm like
tired now because the workout like was
kind of hard it's like oh sure I wasn't
expecting that I was expecting to feel
great after my workout how everyone says
or whatever so you're gonna run into all
these little things that no one tells
you about and then it's like well I
didn't sign up for that little part of
it and then that little part and then
you're gonna have the diet thing I think
you're wrong
I think the diet thing I think if you're
good I think it's very I think it's
easier in fact to just be like I'm done
it's not like okay you know what I'm
only gonna eat a quarter bag of Cheetos
a day from now on I don't think that
works I think you gotta be like no no no
no Cheetos not no Cheetos in my house
but I do think that you could work out
so hard that you're so sore that you
that you say oh man I'm just to like
kind of like the jujitsu question
earlier on like you could be what if
someone's so sore that they can't do
their job right and they're just sore
all day at work well that's not cool so
I think for diet you can you can go cold
turkey or actually cold steak or hot
steak sir and then I think for working
out is the one you you you figure out
what you can do and you push it a little
bit harder but you don't go level nine
Maximum Destruction Madness I think
you're wrong respectfully in which part
do you think I'm wrong on the diet I
think if you go extreme with your diet I
think that it'll work for some people
for sure yeah but depending on who you
are but I think your moral if you go
extremely the diet you don't like slowly
phase out you know it's interesting I
don't know if you remember I read a
letter a while back on the podcast about
a guy that had read way the warrior kid
and he like fixed his life
that guy did what you're saying he just
made little changes yeah he made little
changes along the way so maybe it's
personal it's probably personality in
fact let's just go ahead and say it's
personality because some people are
gonna just have to get the damn Cheetos
out of their house all of them yeah and
some people say you know what I'm only
gonna have this one cup full of Cheetos
every day yeah and even that's okay it
but but here's where you got to be
careful you may lie to yourself oh yeah
and you can lie to yourself yeah I need
a lie to yourself only hey you know I
don't really that that not that big of a
deal today jiff I just have cups Cheetos
yeah yeah yeah nine cups of Cheetos
later see and respectfully I don't like
your Cheetos example why because you're
like I'm gonna allow myself cheat okay
don't allow yourself to doze that's not
how small of a change you're gonna make
if you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore
you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore I'm
saying like if you go extreme on your
diet let's say you eat but wouldn't you
say what you're saying is hey I'm gonna
change my diet okay I used to eat every
day I need a whole bag of Cheetos mhm
and now I'm only gonna eat one cup of
Cheetos from the bag a day
yeah that's improvement it is
improvement it's a small improvement
well and if I could do that then why why
is that not okay yeah okay if you choose
to do that but okay now we're going into
the specifics of a certain person's okay
thing I I would say this this is more
along lines what I'm thinking as far as
specific examples if you're gonna go if
I'm gonna eat one bag of Cheetos
obviously that's not all I'm eating I'm
eating other stuff I'm the small change
is I'm not gonna eat Cheetos anymore I'm
gonna cut out Cheetos that's it
I'm still not eating that good you know
I'm kind of Cheetos or let's say hey I
get you don't drive through every day
three times a day
okay I won't get dressed through anymore
or all that's a big change
not necessarily depending on what you
get going from three Drive thrus a day
to 2-0 the how is that not a big jet
it's a big towers going from like and
there's certain people actually I was
talking to someone the
that had lost a hundred and fifty pounds
female and it was interested her
nutritionist she hired a nutritionist
and the nutritionist said okay what are
the foods you can't live without yeah
and we'll work around those yeah yeah
pretty cool thing yes and what she said
was I need cheeseburgers and fries so
then what she got told was something
along the lines of okay you can have
cheeseburger and fries on Friday
yeah yeah right so the family instead of
you know this this whole thing of I can
never eat it now what I'm saying is
there are people and I think I'm one of
these people where it's like oh if I
have cheeseburgers and fries today well
then I might as well just get a mint
chocolate chip milkshake with it yeah
and if I did that tonight then you know
what tomorrow morning hey after you get
done training maybe if you know that
cheeseburger was good yesterday how
cloud so maybe it's my own personal
weakness but for me I'd prefer to be
just like on the path yeah yeah that's
why the 8020 rule and I talked about
this in the Field Manual the 80/20 rule
maybe it works for some people and I
guess it does work for me but I'd rather
just be straight on the program you know
what I mean
yeah and and then and you know what you
know Tim Ferriss has that thing where
what he's talked about that thing where
he goes six days hardcore strict and
then the seventh day you literally eat
whatever you want as much as you can and
I think I ride that I have and it's
really really good yeah because you feel
really really good not only physically
but just about the whole day I'm on the
program and you kind of know and on that
on that cheat day you do because the
cheat did you eat whatever you want and
you don't feel any guilt at all even
when you're on the 8020 it's like you
have to be coming off a real strong week
to like be to feel good feels very like
cheers are good too yeah and that's
really that bad of a cheat day rise
fries then you're starting to go into it
for sure but the like you know a cheap a
cheat day like a scam hilt
it'll be like for real like a whole
thing of donuts Reeboks a cookie yeah
whatever you
what straight-up whatever you wants is
discussed here's the thing though with
when you when you start to eat healthy
and you then you try to eat a whole box
of donuts you after like one two three
maybe six eight doughnuts you're gonna
be like you know six no not easy
yeah six doughnuts at once oh my gosh
you know those I think they're called
Entenmann's old-fashioned their little
chocolate donuts no you know what a hold
on full-sized don't straight up they're
kind of a little bit bigger too you know
okay six don't ever since I started
talking so much smack about Donuts yeah
I know I can't literally can never have
one again in my life yeah I know you're
not allowed 400 yeah you never have a
bite even if you were like if so knows I
can't just like that when I was a little
kid my parents would buy the chocolate
doughnuts the hostess chocolate yeah
that's that were all covered in
chocolate and those things are good yeah
it can't even have one of those again no
no I did the six-day cheat program no
even then okay I can't do it you know
you know the old-fashioned donut is
right it's like a donut with a hole in
it right no oh it's called old-fashioned
donut they're like um it's they're kind
of glazed and almost like a not they're
not crispy but they're kind of hard are
hard and okay on the outside and then
they're regular soft on that something
say and they have this glaze over them
okay so I think it's I forget the name I
think it might be Entenmann's but they
have old-fashioned doughnuts where
they're not as hard but they're kind of
hard and they're just bigger anyway
those are my favorite ones and I used to
get chocolate milk and heat up the
chocolate milk so it's like hot
chocolate and donuts and oh yeah easy
money like I'll eat two boxes of those
for sure
alright you soon yeah oh yeah so now the
point there is on the cheat day you just
go yeah no shame but after the thing is
you can't just eat donuts four times a
day or three you just don't feel good
like your stomach gets all upset and the
more healthy you eat the more it's gonna
be like that so the longer you're on the
path you start like if you ate some
doughnut like the other day we went to
the Belmont Park and I ate some ice
cream some mint chocolate chip ice cream
was it good
fine it was good but you know all the
kids are doing I never struck
the other night yeah you eat a big large
double you know whatever after that
you're like but I don't feel right you
know so unless you're just committed to
eat it cuz I don't know you don't wanna
waste it or something like that you're
gonna be like all my cheat your cheat
day is not gonna be that bad that's what
I'm saying okay but I still don't have
that I don't make it happen it depends
on what it is yeah yeah yeah you could
pump some chili fries or something I
don't like chili fries all right so yeah
maybe what's the verdict I think just in
there like middle-of-the-road nut the
whole story is it balanced yeah so
you're saying balance as well I'll tell
you though man if that balance doesn't
work for you you're gonna have to step
it up you have to go hardcore I'd give
yourself two weeks two weeks for a
balanced approach on the diet side if
you can't get your under control in
two weeks you got to go hardcore you got
to get in there with a garbage clinic
can throw away the Twinkies throw away
everything else that's crap in your
fridge and yeah and go hardcore that go
and start with a fast to know a a fast
is awesome a fast wait wait there's that
much to expect the only ever a day if
you never done it before it's not that
big of a deal there's no little stuff
don't eat your day there's not take you
from a normal human being this little
stuff they if you're not if you go in
and not prepared for it then you're like
oh I don't know how actually think the
more you think about it prepare for it
the more psychologically or it is just
be like oh yeah you know what I woke up
this morning I haven't eaten last night
calm not gonna eat until tonight
every time I think fast yeah so like
that when I'm like I'm not gonna eat til
this then I go through little stuff but
if I just happen if I be too into work
and I'm only drinking coffee and I
forget I'm like dang if if I eat not
haven't ate for like you know 12 hours
they'll be like oh I'll just go another
three that's my fifteen cuz like 15 or
eight 15 hours is when your body starts
to kind of shift over to like I think 15
okay whatever it's cool so I'll just
wait the extra hour it's like cool done
but if we plan it
that's when yeah I don't know but it
depends on who you are man but that's
good I agree with the fans off yeah a
good way to kick things off and
like jump onto the path yeah just jump
on with a fast yeah hey go see your
doctor or whatever do you if you don't
see a doctor too fast 24 hours I think
you should if you've been probably yeah
oh yeah
fat lazy you know especially if you're
older or something like that I think
Cena doesn't he'll get a personal
trainer depends on the helmet you know
when I just talked to she's like
personal trainer and nutritionist hired
him both he lost 100 whatever pounds so
I think she was in excess of 300 pounds
you know and when I met her she's
completely normal right like you know
completely like you wouldn't even
suspect that she had any weight trouble
in her life yeah that's pretty amazing
yeah
so hire the trainer higher the the
nutritionist yeah I think so I think
that helps I always looked at it like
why would I hire like a trainer or
something like that when I can kind of
look up that stuff but here's the thing
I went in with this bias like cuz I kind
of had a background in it so I'm like
why would I can just go looking but I'm
looking it up but I have all this other
knowledge the same rule you try it for
two weeks
see if you can keep yourself on the path
and if you can't got to bring someone in
right here's what I like hire a trainer
but not like the kind every day it's
like a once a week trainer who can get
you on a little program yeah yeah you
know it's gonna depend on you straight
up you know who can keep you on yeah
that's the mystery of all this and I've
said this a million times like you know
what you need to do yeah you know what
you need to do you know you know what
you need to do if you can't get yourself
to do it maybe you need to give someone
to help you do it yeah the weird thing
is like nutritionists and stuff you can
get nutritionist that could come to you
and be like okay we're gonna go put you
on a low-fat diet you know which would
be really not good thing in the long
term yeah I don't know how many out you
think there's still nutritionist that
are doing that right now
oh yeah there are I know there are
actually they're all they're out there
so you got to be careful right
check next question
last thing that I'm not gonna draw it
out but you said you know what you need
to do and one time you said imagine what
your day would look like like if you'd
like everything you did was you did the
things that you knew you're supposed to
do kind of things well the the full the
full statement is if you wrote down
tonight what you were supposed to do
tomorrow yeah and then you did the
things that you were supposed to do yeah
yeah
imagine how that day would feel and
imagine what you'd get done in that day
yeah and then imagine if he did that
every day for a week
yeah and imagine if you did that every
day for a month and they did for a year
and imagine where your life would be
your life would be in a completely
different trajectory completely
different yeah and that's true with
working out that's true with nutrition
that's true with business that's true
with education that's true with
knowledge it's true with everything
everything yeah kind of know what we're
supposed to do yeah well I thought you
were gonna say some people don't know
what to do and that could be the case
some people they've never worked out
before and if you're a person that's
never worked out before you probably
need to bring someone into the game
that's gonna help show you how to work
out if you've never done any reading
about eating and you have no idea what's
gonna be good for you
you're probably a person that might need
to bring someone into the game to help
you get over that yeah and it still
completely goes with exactly what he
said it's like you know what to do and
even to help that you know what not to
do like when you're about to make a
decision I'm gonna do this or not do
this like you know which one is you
should or shouldn't do so let's say I
don't know anything about working out
but I know I have to get in shape we all
know and you know we all know when we
gotta get in shape so then you know
you're gonna hire somebody you know you
got to do something you know that you
can't just be like oh well I'm not gonna
do it I don't know I'm not gonna do
things to do tomorrow you ain't a
trainer yeah join a gym get a trainer
yeah I don't know what to do okay this
is way you could do find out what to do
there you go in that case so you got
makes sense sometimes you put things and
just say stuff just put it on the table
just starts to make sense
next question I'm a veteran of the
infantry and when I took over a fire
team for the first time I made the
mistake of drawing hard lines in the
sand this immediately alienated members
of that team that had been together for
some time I did not make that mistake
again and I definitely learned from my
experience so clearly there's not a
question there yeah and and I forget
pulling this out from I get a lot of
emails and messages and all that but I
thought it was a good point to bring up
to say you know this idea of drawing
hard lines in the sand and what that
does to your leadership position it's
it's a it's a difficult it's usually not
a good thing to do if you draw a lot of
hard lines in the sand and eventually
you realize that they're either
unrealistic or people can't maintain
them you've set yourself up for failure
what is that exactly like so it's no
matter what we will not go to blah blah
blah yeah there's the leg no matter what
we will we will win every single road
march that we do as a fire team in this
while while we're here on this training
thing mmm okay well guess what that's a
that's hard there's other there's some
other fire teams that are also want to
win and and so you've drawn a hard line
to send that's not really a good example
of a good example it's like no matter
what we're gonna muster every morning at
4:30 in the morning mm-hmm no matter
what and you know then the guys are out
on patrol until 2:38 in the morning and
now the next morning a good no matter
what level it's it's not good for them
it's unrealistic so you drew a hard line
in the sand and now you got to back it
down so and all you have to do is soften
the statement a little bit hey guys
to the best of our ability if we can
we're gonna get here every morning at
4:30 for muster there's a little there's
a little room to play there right and
that's that's fine so again I I there's
there's not a lot of there's not a
question here but one of the reasons I
think that
that I that I wanted to talk about it
was because I think people look at me
and even hear me on a peripheral level
and they think all I bet Chuck will just
lay down the hard night it's my way or
the highway right yeah and and the the
opposite is actually true and the reason
that I came to that conclusion was
because I worked for leaders like that
and I hated working for leaders like
that so I tried to never be a leader
like that hmm and there's a dichotomy
right there's a huge dichotomy because
this doesn't mean that you're not
driving and pushing this doesn't mean
that you're not saying hey we're gonna
be the best one ever we're to be the
best task unit here doesn't mean you're
not saying hey look we're not gonna rest
until we've done what we're supposed to
do doesn't mean that mmm but man you
gotta find that balance yeah it does
feel like that
with you yeah you're like it feels like
that but when you were one I mean it my
experience obviously is we're under no
like extreme circumstances right but
just like just like the simple stuff
like it really does seem like you wake
up at 4:30 in the morning every single
morning do or die
well they said I did that I do unless
like there's some times where I get home
at like I remember a little while ago I
got home at 1 o'clock or 2 o'clock in
the morning mm-hm and that's basically
my cutoff zone if I'm getting less than
four and a half hours of sleep then I'll
be like oh yeah I'll wake up and I've
been like hey I only got two and a half
hours of sleep last night that's not
enough I'm going back to bed right
that's it that's what I mean where I've
tweeted that out before yeah higher yeah
yeah that's what I mean
yeah so it's like when when that happens
it almost like he catches you off guard
you know wouldn't you do when you did
that I mean obviously not like oh cool
daughter's trick it's not that feeling
at all it's just kind of like oh dang
you do have that flexibility when you
know when it's the correct thing kind of
yeah you have to yeah you're not a slave
tier uh rigidity well what you're saying
is I don't draw hard lines in the same
yeah exactly right but it's real easy to
go down the slippery slope of like well
I you know I I actually didn't eat real
good yesterday so I probably need some
more sleep to recover today yeah yeah
yeah really yeah well I am I'm it's a
rest day so I might as well turn on the
TV oh you know I'd be good with TVs
maybe some popcorn
oh you know it'd be good with some
popcorn maybe some cheese sticks in some
M&Ms it's resting right yeah it went
down the slippery wall back so I guess I
guess the opposite of the of the of the
path is the slippery slope exactly right
next question hi scenario that's
actually a legit way to think of it too
yeah if it's a legit way to think of
things if you're on the path when you
know what the path is as we talked about
with Tim Ferriss if you're on the path
which you know well when you step off
the path it's a slippery slope you know
it's a off the path is the slippery
slippery slope and yeah what did you
just say the popcorn can lead to cheat
sticks can lead to mmm yeah that's the
slippery slope right there yeah and
sometimes you slip so hard that you just
plunge deep off the path yeah fall off
the wagon land hard scenario my team
leaders boss came to me and asked my
opinion on my horrible team leader the
boss my boss's boss one of my opinion so
what do I do
praise him to make the team look good
and maintain my relationship with my
with the team leader or tactfully tell
the truth and build a relationship with
the boss with my boss's boss yeah that's
a good question isn't it I think this is
a it's a really tough position to be in
yeah because you have to be careful and
you have to be balanced and there's a
couple things to think about first of
all no one likes rats
Yeah right mm-hmm no one likes rats but
at the same time you kind of also have
to think about what's best for the team
on top of and kind of the opposite of no
one likes rats is no one likes brown
nosers no but at the same time you have
to build relationships up and down the
chain of command and one of the toughest
things about this and what you have to
be so careful about is that you don't
know what kind of relationship the boss
and the team leader have you don't know
four on one end of the spectrum they
could be friends so if you say something
bad about him that's going right back to
the team leader and you're in you're
gonna have a hard time you're in a much
worse position also they could be
enemies and supporting the team lead to
the boss could actually make you look
stupid
right making make you look bad and and
it's important to say here is it the
optics of like I don't want to look bad
is that what I'm talking about because
that's what I just said like it'll make
you look bad I'll make you look stupid
the reason that you're trying to look
good is because you want to do a good
job because you want the team because
you want the mission to succeed that
that's what's important and you don't
care I don't care if I have to eat crow
I don't care if so so I don't mind
looking bad if it's for a good reason I
don't mind my ego taking a ding if it's
for the right reason but this could
actually hurt the way I do my job mmm
because now my boss my boss sorry my
boss's boss thinks I'm kind of an idiot
and so that means when promote comes
time for promotion even though I might
be the best guy I'm not getting promoted
because I was the guy that was too blind
to see that my team leader was an idiot
yeah so I would be very careful and
fairly neutral in what I said especially
to start with right so you know if the
boss says hey how's that team leader
doing my responsibility you know we get
the job done there's that's so
non-committal right well what about the
team leader is he is he a good leader
I think he's I think he's got a pretty
good hold of what's going on right so
that's that's there's room to interpret
that in any direction really I think
he's got a pretty good hold all right I
think he's getting a hold of what's
going on or another one would be well
hey how's your team leader I think our
performance kind of shows where we're at
right so you're not you're not giving
away and those are those are like I said
those are subtle and those are very open
things that you could respond to and and
I think the more your boss probes or the
sorry the mo the team boss team leaders
bosses probes the more you could open up
a little bit
still with caution but as you see what
the boss's opinion is you could open up
a little bit more and share a little bit
more of the truth very tactfully or if
or you could go in the other direction
right if you just oh you know that's my
best guy and I've known bill forever it
bills I brought him here and Bill's
gonna be he's going places mmm so you're
gonna derail that guy you you can but
you're probably derail yourself too
because that guy has a legitimate
relationship with so that's a tough
situation and and I would say the best
thing to do in this situation is remain
as neutral as possible and again you
know what there's there's someone that's
listening or to this right now that's
going on jock was kind of a jock was
kind of a wimp and if I was there I just
tell the truth okay so let's let's talk
about that let's talk about what happens
because I've been in that situation more
times than I can count where my boss was
kind of an idiot and I get asked by his
boss hey how's this guy doing so let's
say you rat him out well does that mean
that the boss gets fired immediately no
it just means that your team is less
respected it means that you get less
support it means and if you do get
ratted out by the way where do you end
up now you end up in a bad situation
where the your boss knows that you
ratted him out to his boss you're hated
yeah you're hated
I want to win let's go back to that
point I want to win hmm so does it help
me win if I rat out my boss or if I rat
out my team leader to my boss does it
help me win it could it could if your
boss happens to be completely aligned
with what you're thinking he also
happens to have a replacement ready
that's more squared away that's another
thing you get rid of one bad team leader
now you get a new team leader how do you
know him who's that who is that person
where'd they come from the Devils what
is that saying the devil you know is
better than the devil that you don't
know so if I have a team leader that's
not doing a good job whose fault is that
yeah I can help my team leader
especially if my team leader is weak I
can help them become strong I can help
teach them tactfully not stepping on
their toes I would rather rather than
wrap my team leader out up the chain of
command
I would rather fix my team leader I
would rather help my team leader become
better support them and by the way when
you do support your team leader and they
become better and now they do come up
for a promotion what do they know in the
back of their mind they know that you
helped them they knew they know that you
got him there guess who's getting
promoted now you are now why am I so
concerned about getting promoted it's
because I want to want to outdo everyone
else no that's not why so you want to
win because I want to win I want the
team to win and if I thought that you
eko would do a better job if you became
team leader instead of me I'd be like
hey I appreciate it but echo would do a
better job than me he should be the team
leader so and and also if you're real
this is what happens if I'm really a
person this this is this this is what
I'm getting at if I'm really a person
that really wants to get promoted and
that's my main goal I want to get
promoted that's my goal what do I do
with the team leader I throw him under
the bus so that's the person that we all
hate the person that rats out the team
leader that that says oh that guy's
doing a terrible job I'd do much better
job and gets that guy fired and now I
get promoted what do we all think of
them we all think that guy is a turd
now as opposed to this someone that says
you know what our team leaders a week
needs help need support I'm gonna help
them I'm gonna support them I'm gonna do
the best I can wait are you saying to
tell the boss this or just have that you
had a bad like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna from one of the bus now if we have
a guy that's horrible that's tyrannical
that does a horrible job that abuses
people then we get to a situation where
you say you know what boss there are
some problems yeah so if you have that
one which doesn't really well this guy
says horrible team leader so if this is
a horrible team leader that's
irredeemable irredeemable qualities and
it's negatively affecting the team cuz
he kind of makes it sound like make the
team look good so there's there's
there's still a possibility that the
team is doing okay ya know they have a
horrible leader because they are such
good troops I said I would see that
sometimes a platoon has a bad leader but
there's great guys in there and the
platoon leader is smart enough to be
like okay I'm gonna let them kind of run
with it and they'll be successful yeah
so my goal usually is to help the person
above me in the chain well it's always
to help the person above me attain a
command can you get to a situation where
someone is so bad that it's negatively
affecting the whole team and you can't
win because they're positioned yes well
then you need to step up and do
something about it and say something
about it
do it tactfully do it slowly don't over
commit to your statements early on
because if you do you might say
something that is out of line mm-hmm so
that's it's a tricky situation there's
no definitive answer you have to weigh
these things out yeah generally if you
can help someone win you're gonna win
generally if you help someone win you're
gonna win if it's so bad that they're
just bringing down the whole team and
you cannot win with them in that
position you might need to say something
yeah especially if everyone on the team
kind of feels the same way it's gonna be
a little bit easier to be like hey you
know yeah and be straight yeah but even
if everyone if we if we have the gang
mentality right like hey man the boss
sucks you know what he's team leaders
horrible he doesn't know what he's doing
hey
guys you know what we just sit here
complain about it or we could actually
try and like make him a better leader
yeah yeah well what do you guys say
think of that and then because hey we
could try and get a replacement for him
but at least he listens to us right now
or whatever you know at least he's at
least he understands the job hey let's
try and let's try and prop him up let's
try and get you know what let's get rid
of him but let's get rid of him by
teaching him a lot so he gets educated
so he can move on and get promoted and
then we'll have a good relationship with
him
yeah and then the team will get more
support and then we can do our mission
better yeah yeah I guess he kind of
doesn't understand what makes them
accountable for sure first like what if
what if I don't like him because I don't
like his tie I don't know I don't like
his hairdo you know I just don't like
him we don't we don't come from the same
side of the tracks I don't know what I
don't think one of the things that would
be like if the guys arrogant yeah the
guys arrogant well how are we gonna
bring him down how are we gonna break
well how we not not bring him down like
bring him down from his job but how we
gonna bring down his ego yeah how you
gonna mellow him out you know and that
could that could be a long project hmm
that could be a long project yes so just
like I you said is like it is it
damaging that the performance kind of
thing yes that's the most important
thing is it what is our performance like
yeah can we bring this guy around good
question
I'm sorry there's no definitive answer
but at the same time there's leadership
is is an art yeah and why did the it's
an art and science but it's an art sir
this is a case where the artistic part
is going to be more important yeah yeah
yeah
the dichotomy all right it's a number
one bloodsport how we called martial
arts martial science called it martial
science the guy what is named since a
Tanaka right come on bro bloodsport
Bend em yeah no I know I know what the
movie is called it's a familiar with
that too familiar even as a kid I
thought those movies were really cheesy
yeah cheesy like so many like a lot a
lot of MMA well I guess from my age MMA
gosh you know I was in the bloodsport
you know yeah even when I was a kid I
will I wasn't thinking blood sport was
like legit I don't know why I thought it
was but we get
the dim I've got rock you I thought
Rocky was more legit yeah okay still
yeah I thought I thought that Rocky was
more legit then blood sport for me blood
sport seemed fake yeah yeah I guess
right it just seemed extreme I guess cuz
but plus I think with blood sport the
rumors circulated that that guy was real
real you know
so you're like oh sure it's a movie cool
made it fun but it was really yeah yeah
again III wouldn't say I hated
bloodsport but like I haven't seen it
enough to know that the guy referred to
martial arts as martial science that was
early uh early in the movie when Van
Dam's teacher you know it's your typical
movie right there's a there's a guy he's
getting beat down or whatever he goes
through his training process there's a
there's a montage like in the team or
Team America world police there's a
montage training montage and then he
comes back and went that there's there's
like most of your fight movies yeah you
know the montage yeah he gets beat done
early
you know he trains he becomes awesome
but then there's the arch enemy who's
trained to yeah but still a bully and he
has to beat him same thing with credit
kid but you're leaving out the montage
part a training montage yeah which is
very important you're the best
no that's credit kid yeah you ever seen
the movie never back down no okay so you
wouldn't you'll never watch this movie
it's it's it's MMA right it's I remember
when it came out yeah yeah yeah but it's
basically Karate Kid it's it's literally
like Karate Kid but just MMA now and a
little bit more cheesy maybe a lot more
cheesy I thought it was good though I
enjoyed it and watch them watch me learn
from like a master jujitsu guy or
something yeah Brazilian guy who plays
is played by an African guy the guy on
your remember gladiator you know
gladiator right Russell Crowe any of the
black guy in there the African guy
vaguely yeah he um you know the one yeah
the main friend he's the guy but he's a
Brazilian guy okay it doesn't match cuz
I don't know Brazilian X I was gonna say
houses on Portuguese accent no haha I
still African but nonetheless you know
on paper it might seem cool but it came
out kind of cheesy no I liked it though
you know they overemphasize
like all the things like he goes to the
party and the party is just me way yeah
look into it nonetheless yes science and
art I dig it you kind of have to buy me
back the question yeah I have to kind of
wonder why the boss is asking your
opinion - is it just a general probe
like hey how you guys doing how's the
boss doing kind of like that
or is it we have some concerns about
your team leader what up you know kind
of thing yeah and even that you got to
be careful yeah because they could lead
you down that path maybe maybe they're
probing you yeah yeah maybe the leader
said hey you know what I don't trust
this guy he says about me
right and then you go in and you go hey
I've heard some bad things about this
guy what do you think of them yeah I'll
tell you what you're right that guy's
our dude yeah
turd with years yeah a lot of teammates
they turned the team thing I think I
think it came from buds at some point
yes it was you'd get called turds quite
a bit and then a person that was kind of
maybe just just not a very good
individual would be a turn in years
anyway they say you do boy same thing do
do boy do - boy yeah but obviously not
in any kind of discipline said we're
here one more one more question yes next
question last question chuckle I've been
disciplined working hard and staying
focused but I've hit a run of bad luck
and I can't seem to get a break well
first of all you are lucky because if
you're capable of of working hard then
that's a blessing that's luck because
there's people
all over the world that don't have the
ability for any number of reasons many
of those reasons being just bad luck
that they can't work so right out of the
gate you're lucky that you can get up
tomorrow and you can go to work now you
say you can't get a break and maybe
you're getting unlucky with your career
or your personal life or your business
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
give up are you gonna surrender are you
gonna assume that because you didn't
catch a break today there's no way
you'll catch one tomorrow or next week
or next year are you going to leave in
all the chance or are you going to do
everything in your power to force lock
your way to create opportunity to to
shift the hands of fate and even then if
the break never comes even if you roll
across the finish line of life bruised
and bloodied and empty-handed from the
fight at least you know you know that
you went after it as hard as you could
then you gave life everything you had
and you know in the end you might still
be unlucky
that could happen but I would much
rather be an unlucky soul that fought
until the end and died with my sword in
my hand then an unlucky soul that's
submitted bow down gave up and
surrendered so stop waiting to get lucky
stop waiting for a big break instead be
thankful truly thankful for what you do
have and go out there and fight and
battle and brawl to make your own luck
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo just speaking of fighting hard
sure is there anything you know about
that can help us stay in the fight stay
in the fight continue fighting art check
sure first thing you do need to do is
take care of your body habitus use that
word wrong but body habitus is like your
move like your habitat on your body
anyway take care of your body is what I
meant including but not limited to your
joints a lot more important than I
thought from the beginning or at in the
beginning so how you do that is super
krill oil Jocko has super krill oil
chocolates krill oil called super krill
oil another supplement called joint
warfare these are good for your joints
don't neglect them that's how you see in
the fight straight out get them at
origin main comm also you want to
increase your capacity and capability in
the fight physically mentally
you take new product called discipline
it's called discipline it's not
discipline itself it's called discipline
anyways cognitive and physical enhancer
force multiplier mental plus physical
the the sum is greater than the parts
anyway
origen main calm that's where you get
them really good they also have use in
rash guards they're at origin me and
they are all made in America I don't
know if you know this it's a big deal he
does good work over there from the dirt
to the shirt yeah cotton is even grown
in America and that's very important see
what I did there
jockeys rash guards compression gear
pants compression pants spats all
they're also or just speaking of origin
we have an immersion camp jiu-jitsu
immersion camp all levels of jiu-jitsu
are welcome to this by the way what
about kids kids welcome to that one I
don't think so
the AK is something they have the
capacity for kids there yeah shoot
they're asking me that interesting
nonetheless all levels even if you don't
have any jiu-jitsu at all in fact last
time there was a group who didn't have I
think it was like some didn't have any
dude no dude it just came to win unless
like you know like some of the stuff you
learn if you don't have any juice it's
like okay that's not gonna fit into my
knowledge because you have no knowledge
so it's like that's not I don't
understand this quite yet you get it
like no we did they're like the
fundamentals class for him yeah yeah
yeah and even during um like while he
was going on I I had a group on the site
of like a good like 12 people and we're
just doing just the basic no no yes yeah
for sure all levels and by the way if
you're a beginner yeah that's cool but
also if you're good you'll also get some
awesome training there yeah everybody
great guys there yeah huge good it's
cool yeah it's all butts up in Maine
Echo Lake I really like this everyone oh
yeah we yeah crank yeah yeah Echo Lake
Echo's got his own Lake sure Echo Park
Echo Lake dang nonetheless yeah so yeah
origin mancom you can look and see all
that stuff and you know if you want
something get something if you want to
come to the emergency camp come to the
immersion camp I'll be there
chuckling yeah you so mad last time you
couldn't do that your rib yeah read
Braille rib was Jackson this year won't
be jackets no no no either way
also for fitness gear when a very of
your workout you want to implement new
movements kettlebells d-do kettlebells
I know JA can you do kettlebells I know
that but that's the question yeah you do
Mike grand chief right Mike this guy you
know he's a brown belt or black belt I
forget I'm in Carlsbad area you know
I've known him for a long time I used to
work with his sister I don't even know
if he remembers that but so watching you
know you know Jeff Clark yes yeah yes he
hit me up he was like hey I want to get
into kettlebells now he's like I'm
looking at the on it ones or whatever
you know asking the advice here's the
thing I'm not an expert on the
kettlebells but I do know this don't get
nuts with them but don't go too late
either though I bought a kettlebell for
my daughter she's five now so it's just
it looks cool it's like one of the
little hundred four kilograms the
smallest one yeah but when I pick that
up I'm like no matter what fitness level
I'm at this isn't gonna do much for me
so don't go too late is what I'm saying
yeah yeah nonetheless get them from on
it go on it calm slash chuckles some
good stuff a lot of options there you
think you're stuck in a boring Jocko
workout super hard but but boring you're
gonna fall off that way again maybe I
don't know depends on me your butt if
you want to vary it up go on it doc on
slash chuckle get some do some good
finish good
also when you're getting any of the
books that we review on this podcast I
got am organized for you on jockle
podcast comm click on the top books book
section I think specifically it says
books from chaco podcasts got them
organized by episode
including Rob Jones journeys journal by
the way pretty much anything that we're
reading I'm gonna put it on there for
access easy access and it happens to
support takes you to Amazon boom get
your book two-day delivery one-day
delivery eight-hour delivery sometimes
and you know it's gonna do other
shopping continue on do you be you also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already iTunes stitcher Google Play a
Spotify stitcher I already said to do it
everywhere yeah everyone whatever you
listen to podcasts on subscribe yeah
seems obvious right
also YouTube if you are interested in
the video version of this podcast go and
see what chocolate looks like if you
care you'll see what I look like if you
care which may be a little bit more of a
thing because I don't sound how I look
still get that by the way yeah no I just
talked to a guy about the other day
yeah yes yesterday that'll never go away
huh nope until everyone has seen me no
one sees me anyway if you are interested
in that youtube video version of this
podcast also excerpts take little chunks
out of the podcasts and post them so you
can share them so they don't have to
listen to two and a half three hours of
a whole podcast again one lesson one
specific lesson that's not a YouTube
channel and you just made a new video I
did yeah I'm making more videos now time
is running out time is running out it's
no video short doing you know the you
know so I'll choose little excerpts or
whatever it to be like you know what
this one to me
hit harder this little message that you
said and that one was cuz it is one of
those ones cuz you know how they the old
saying where it's like yeah we know we
had to have a limited time on this earth
but we don't act like it yeah you know
that whole thing and really when you
think about that that's more true than I
think most people realize and you know
that's why people go through like
midlife crisis right you know they they
hit a certain age I'm gonna get my ears
pierced and get a Corvette yeah I don't
know you know it's that scrambling
situation you know you trying to
scramble to get get more in but you know
there's gonna come a time you can't do
that there
a little old-school footage in there in
that video
yeah - oh if you want to see me when I
was I don't like 13 or 14 sure maybe
yeah I was probably 14
I'm gonna guess 14 Bronson's children
Bronson's children
what's that Bronson snatchin nonsense
that was straight up it is right yeah
okay - identify fully the actual because
we had a bunch of different names one of
the names of the band was rage of
discipline the range of discipline but
it was never disciples of discipline no
this one it was rage of discipline you
know and it was it was struggle it was
Lock and Load which is really
militaristic for someone that wasn't in
the military to be like my bands called
lock and load
I realize how cheesy that is now that's
really dope back well I don't know but
anyways rage of disciplines real
military ish seem bright you were you
even before yeah that's what the guy you
got the video footage from Elgin James
he what he comes on the podcast he's
okay I'm gonna tell people he I actually
just spoiler alert exact I can't wait to
tell everyone that you had a band called
rage of discipline when you were 14
years old no yeah and I was kind of
laughing about that yeah yeah but yeah
you're in the making from the beginning
yeah yeah I guess you could say that but
you know also I I also look back and
think well man I did some dumb stuff
when I was a kid yeah well you didn't
get a handle on the discipline till
later but you know the seed was there
you know like a little rattlesnake you
know how they say they're the most
dangerous because they can't control the
venom they don't have the discipline oh
but they want the discipline that's what
I think that's what I was like a little
rattlesnake yes right nonetheless you
can see these videos on you well the
video is a cool video
yeah thanks Joe good job echo Charles
thanks should I do more videos also
Chuck was a store called jaco store this
is where you can get discipline equals
freedom shirts there's that word again
discipline you know
iconic one also rash guards on their
women's stuff on their hoodies on their
beanies here's the thing be nice out a
little bit more of a process but I mean
approved and you know there's gonna be
some beanies on their new shirt is out
just in time for summer good job even
there they'll need him down in
Australian New Zealand yeah it was
summertime down there yeah in the
southern hemisphere yeah in Hawaii
you're wearing a new shirt today that's
right is this out back to the book it's
out its out it's available because I
didn't say anything I just kind of snuck
it on there so some people got it so
it's live its life or in life or add a
video book back to the book it's
actually good the front of it has a book
on the back has all the titles that
you've reviewed or
you know gonna see what that looks like
Jaco store calm if you want something
get something it's a good way to support
also psychological warfare if you know
what that is it's an album with tracks
that each track is engineered it's not
music tracks chocolate tracks engineered
to help you through any moment of
weakness that you may stumble upon or
that might stumble upon you
Ike you shouldn't say stumble upon you
because that kind of gives the ownership
to like oh it happens to me
yet I mean if you hit weakness you hit
the weakness like you you stumbled on
the weakness you can't blame the
weakness you blame you see I'm saying
sure so any moment weakness that you
happen to stumble upon there's a track
for that procrastination waking up early
the diet stuff falling off the diet
wagon you want to eat some donuts
because they're free at work it's
wasteful if you don't eat them it's
disrespectful to the person who bottom
and your your you're gonna eat them
that's weak stay on the path and if you
need a little spot psychological warfare
you can get it on iTunes Amazon music
various where we can purchase mp3s both
get it from their psychological or her
it's a good one good way to support to
by the way a way to support also if you
need some more support you can get
Jacque a white tea
and I've got some bad news and good news
bad news
they've started testing for jock a white
team so they started testing they're
worried you know they see guys just
dominating and they're thinking they're
probably on jakka white tee the good
thing that's the bad news
good news is doesn't matter can't test
for it all-natural it's all natural no
one can believe that a fully natural
substance can can raise any human beings
deadlift to eight thousand pound minimum
but there it is it is factual
factual books all right books you can
get some books weigh the warrior kid
this is the book for kids the book for
kids see the feedback go on go on social
media go on Twitter go on Facebook you
Bo ha and see kids studying see kids
doing pull-ups see kids doing jiu-jitsu
see kids getting after it that'll tell
you right there so many parents have
said I can't believe my kid now wants to
study as they post little pictures of
kids making math flashcards that's what
I'm talking about imagine if you get
your kid to do math flashcards
voluntarily boom so that's what I'm
talking about and now there's a way the
warrior kid to Mark's mission in this
book Uncle Jake teaches young mark and
he really teaches the rest of us how to
control his temper how to work hard how
to be frugal and smart with money
there's a little entrepreneurial
activity in the book he also learns how
to take care of his gear he learns how
to save his money he learns how to deal
with insults and with verbal abuse and
he learns to overcome his fear of
failure that's a lot to learn in one
book yeah but it's there
the lessons are there and it's done in a
simple clear way that only uncle Jake
knows how to do and speed of
entrepreneurial or your kids don't
forget about Aiden young Aiden he's only
12 years old but he has a business he's
making soap from goat milk from goats on
his farm
and he's not just making any soap he's
making good soap he's making Jacko's
soap mmm you can order it at Irish red
Irish Oaks ranch calm and the motto
which I thought have not given Aiden any
credit for this he didn't think of this
motto I thought of the motto the motto
is stay clean so ya get yourself some
chocolate so you can also get a book
called the discipline equals freedom
Field Manual
and that's another book the feedback is
awesome the feedback is awesome people
that get that book and they get on the
path they get stronger healthier smarter
more disciplined they're get better and
they live a better life and that's
awesome to hear so if you or someone you
know needs to know how to get on the
path and stay on the Baths path then the
field manual is for them and it'll help
them do just that and for the audio
version it's not inaudible because then
you can't have an album with tracks the
audio version is on iTunes Amazon music
google play other mp3 platforms so if
you want the audio version get that also
obviously there's a book called extreme
ownership it is combat leadership these
are the lessons that we learned in
combat translated into leadership
principles for business and life and you
know what still on the on the sound
charts right now is number 17 on all
Amazon charts for books red or something
like that so yeah you got to dig that
it's still selling and and and also
announcement just went over a million
copies sold yeah which is pretty legit
so thanks everyone for doing that for
buying some books some copies of books
and by the way you don't sell a million
copies of a books of a book on just hype
and and we didn't do it through paid
advertising which I don't even know if
you could do it through paid advertising
the book sells because the word of mouth
so everyone that listens this podcast
buys the book spreads the word gets it
for other people your
reason that that book is selling so well
still so thank you all for spreading the
word telling people get it for them get
it for their team up and down the chain
of command extreme ownership pick it up
furthermore national on front that's my
leadership and management consulting
company we solve problems through
leadership that's what we do and that is
how all problems get solved through
leadership so it's me it's lave babban
it's JP Danelle it's Dave Burke you can
email info and echelon front com or you
can go to the website s LAN front comm
and of course we are approaching the
muster this is the most dynamic
leadership conference ever of all time
tickets are selling we've already kind
of expanded the floor in the location
that we have in DC as much as we can to
accommodate more people but I'm telling
you it's gonna sell out we're only doing
two musters this year one is in
Washington DC May 17th and 18th and one
is in San Francisco October 17th and
18th so come learn hang out get your
pragmatic leadership skills and also
it's important to know that there's no
green room there's no backstage will be
there hanging out answering questions
talking eating working out and hanging
out with everyone that shows up so join
us there you can register at extreme
ownership calm and also on extreme
ownership calm there's a document that
we put together so some people they want
to come to the conference they need to
run it up their chain of command and
they kind of say what should I say up my
chain of command
I want my chain of command to pay for
which is awesome and the chain of
command should pay for it because
they're gonna get back a much better
leader in their organization but we put
a document on there you can you can
click on the link that the little what's
that that little link I guess it's
called the Lincolnshire
called creating leaders at every level
and that's also on extreme ownership
calm we'll see you there we'll see you
at the muster and until we do see you at
the mustard you can find us interacting
and conversing and cruising on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
that double hockey Becca is that echo
Charles and I am at jockey willing and
thanks to those of you out there and
uniformed around the world on foreign
lands in the sky over our heads and on
and under the high seas protecting us
from the evil of the world thank you and
thanks to police and law enforcement to
the firefighters and paramedics and all
of you first responders thanks for
taking care of us and our families when
we need it most and to everyone else out
there the nurses and the doctors working
all hours to heal us and the teachers
trying to educate our youth and the guys
hanging drywall and pouring concrete and
roughing in plumbing and electrical and
the farmers growing crops and the
factory workers building products and
the fishermen and the lobstermen and the
longshoremen and the bankers and the
advisors and the salespeople and the
waitresses and the cooks and the
dishwashers to all the men and women
across the land and every job in every
capacity that show up everyday thanks
for listening to us and thanks for doing
your job and doing it well and doing it
with pride and thanks for working hard
to make your own luck and to make your
part of the world a better place by
going out there and getting after it and
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko
out